興味高校卒業なんですよおいは起訴し高校3ですみんな卒業腕とまぁおかあだぞ
thunderbolt ぞ
あ
こんにちは行きです分 i5任せたら乳業カード始めて6年経ったぜ買えま
俺は気付いてしまったぜ遊戯王カードの楽しみ方はデッキの強さだけじゃない
魔法カード発動ガチデッキでた外的
作ってみた
二相棒遊戯王カードというのは最近高いんだよ俺は気付いてしまったんだよ大会カード
はたっくさんあることは知っている
でも高いカードっていうのはデュエル用じゃないんだぶっちゃけていうとコレクション
用例えば俺が持てるブラックマジシャンガールの本物とかも
あれ弱いも弱いのに高いカードは実践のデールでは使えない
つ毎ターンの飾り物なれそう
とだけ語弊があるんですけど高いからもすごいですよコレクション用の高い可能すごい
んですけども
俺が目指せるのは強くても高いかもうコレクション鷹山なく実践のデュオ使える
ガチデッキで高いデッキをもう3年ぐらいかけて高い方を集めてようやく完成したので
今日はそれの根太を調べるぜ
はなしっ
[音楽]
4試合道さっそく見ていこう安心する相棒
今日の動画は遊戯王が分からないというのもわかりやすいように噛み砕いて説明して
いくぜ
逆に言うとガチ勢からするとちょっとわかりづらいかもしれないんですけどもわから
ない人でもわかりやすく遊戯俺のデッキお値段説明していこうと思いますまあ3年間
くらいずっと使ってきた銭湯っていう女の子のレイちゃんという女の子たち
なんて気があるんですけどもカートっていうのはレアリティがあるわけですね光って
ないカードまではギラギラに光っているカードちょっとで光っているカードがいろんな
種類があるですけども
先頭にギラギラカードでは食っちゃったんですよね火災決めずのティックれ野党
シークレットでっていうギラギラ光ってるからおすごい高いんですけども aibo
俺のこの敵機は全部最高レアリティ俺の予想だと多分100万届くのかな
ってぐらいのデッキを作ってみましたの勝ちですなんかのコレクター的に高い必ず
エビルナイトドラゴンとかああいうの全部抜きで勝ち月に大会の戦える強さと値段を
備えた
史上最強のデッキもうここ1年かけて集め理由って予約カフェしたので今日はその値段
見ていくぜ俺をターン
ドアドローっていう場合にはこの3部でね
先頭にネイチャーのセリフなんですけどもビューエリスはスリーブからディールが
始まってるんですね
戦闘機成分でた見ていきましょう値段どうやって調べるかというとアナゾンの金額で見
ていきますメルカリと母よりちょっと高いんですよね2だ安心に安全で早く届く
ちょっと高いんですけど色々加えるとアマゾンで母が一番簡単かなということであ謎の
皆を参考に見ていくぞ
by boe 卓球にしたぜ35000です
はっ
では早速デッキの値段見ていきましょうまずは俺のターンドロー
戦闘きれいの20th シークレットレアですねこの花のめちゃ曲で私ほぼこの俺の
デッキの出身校とってもいいカードです3万入ってます a 6なぁ十全657 in
大熱段タイプやっ思って6型チャペックじゃなきゃさん
やばこれ一枚7万円くらいでだいたい工夫
路やばもうだってこれさん内で21万円ですよ
相棒見てくれよこれやっぱり値段だけで光り方がすごいんですよもう
例えば可愛くてキラキラ光ってるのっていう行が高くなる傾向があるんですよ
それにしても高い俺のターンドロー俺は手札から戦闘ヒロ0
3体召喚また女の子ですねカワイイ0 zu カードのてレディースシークレットには
2枚です
何枚かあるんですけど安い方を選ぶと孫版3000円ですね
2枚で106,000円第列あったいっ
やっぱ中万石山って ilo 攻撃力じゃ計れないもんがある
2枚106,000円
位の中大時間今スリーブとこの5枚障害下げれば35万円入ってます続いて俺のターン
ドロー
俺はてきたから増殖する g 43倍召喚この増殖する g も20th 刺激打っ
てりゃと言ってもう今は手に入らない相当高いカードだなんてこんなゴキブリみたいな
カードが高いんだろう
ua
か amazon で安くて39,800円4万円ですね
4万円3枚で12万円ダイエットはタイプ
風中にはゴキブリ3枚で12万困難でも皆さん4番するんですよ
これだからやめられてるぜああここず取っ手付きますフォルタンドローンエフェクト
ヴェーラー c グってるよ
今井昇桓昔からあるカードですね
あーでもそこそこいい値段するな2095年2000円くらいですね
2枚で4000円ですまあマグっていうのは4銭安いって感じちゃう
道路
きたぜ俺が出るだから春だな
3枚召喚最近シャハルエラーのかわいいイラストのリズムピクシーペット屋さん眉です
普通なイラストもあるんですけどもこのへ違いがすごい高いんで買いました
うん愛撫挟んスターズ強いんですよね全部のデッキに絶対入るようなカードなんで
そもそも重要がすごいですね4
はぁ
じゃあばいいだすと次の春が一番71,500円
第劇団タイプこれだが高い d わからずにかわいいんですよ
総合的に見てやっぱり高くてもいいかなとかなって俺はぜ相棒チャードしくなってきた
ぜ俺のターン
道路てくだから屋敷私を召喚イラストめっちゃかわいいんですよ最近の環境もさせて
いるカードでとっても強いです富士爪チェックし
プレートで一番800円約1万円ですね1万円ですもうスター母が子
で終了ここから魔法カード発動
テラフォーミングテラフォーミングの prismatic していけると言われ光り
方がマジで月ないんですけどもね団子ふわぁ結構高い
6,280円だいたい6000円ぐらいにしておきましょうかこれまでは安いのがあれ
ば本当にもう100円もしないくらいで売ってます
レアリティは人をダメにするで俺のちゃん
てだから新車蘇生発動これ2017年の有業な世界大会はなんかプロモーションカード
でうわぁ
2個で約8万円の死者蘇生うわぁ凄い俺の射精はもうスターを
83よみがえらせるテイクだから魔法カード金満で研究
月穂3枚髪を昔からあるツボのカードですね
遊戯王カード私から都合のカードが多いんですけれどもそれの最近の流行ってるって
本当は一番下しか入れないで起こったんですけども値段を上げるために3枚れたぜ1枚
9000円ですねだいたい
¥27,000孫がぁ土讃線の左右2枚発動
prismatic c グッドですこれもね役立つ買うのは
んですよ¥4,118代々4100円くらいですね
魔法カード成金ゴブリン発動成金ゴーリー発動
なにこれはできから版ドロシー貴様の大ポイントを1000回復する正しい来るとレア
3993約4000円12,000円さらに俺はデブだから増援発動
救援 tcc goodwear
俺はできから戦士族モンスターを持ってくるぜ5,500円ここからちょっと戦闘機な
魔法カードなんで馴染みがないかも知れませんどんどんいきます b ドランカー2枚
発動
prismatic シークレットであるです4,250円と3,318円があるので
まぁ間をとって3500円くらいにしましょう
戦闘機動エンゲージ2枚 c
ベルトです鳥はそんなドンをやっ末やっす80円なんですけど
20160円です
悲しい8日日スタートなんで絶対いるんですよねやす次いでマルチロール2枚
めちゃくちゃ2カードです400外れ選挙区制
活動生活まぁまぁだいたい似ていないかなまぁだいたいそうが2000円ぐらいだと
思います2枚で4000円どういう風な壺を発動ベイリーフですこれならたの知ってる
って多いんじゃないかこのカードは4000円くらいショックかたぶん4000円
くらいだと思います
方カードハープへの羽箒発動これを知っている人が多いでしょう
魔法トラップカードを全部破壊するカードです点500円くらいです
俺のデッキにある唯一のトラップカード3枚全部発動
夢幻泡影グリーン this secret リアですうわぁタッカ
21,900円25,800円21,000円くらいかな
最後に跳ね上がったぜ無限方
3倍では6万3000円くらい残りの戦闘機カードですこれそんなに高くないちょっと
まとめて掲載します
5枚でだいたい1600円階ですねうううっ
遊戯もビックリ
i バー
俺のメインできる値段が今わかった俺が戦闘機でき
値段が
9017,960円
これでターンエンドだ
母アートさんこれはされましたペンとうとうくんっていうカードガール絶対使うカード
なんですけどもこれのウルトラレア度高いんだぜ
うわぁ67,800円で売ってましたこれを含めると98万7000360へ
第がまだ慌てるのは速いぜ相棒僕からはエクストラできる値段見ていきましょう
リンク召喚戦闘機かがり prismatic シークレットリアのイラスト違い
うわぁ1万円は絶対入ってますね
1万円ですさらにリンク章元林院町甲日朝間戦闘機雫ペンティシー good や一番
この戦闘機の中で好きな3試してみます青くて可愛いです誰か
いいところ7万ぐらいで売ってるし安いとこだと3万円くらいですね
3万円にしておきましょうか3枚で9万円です戦闘機疾風は3枚リンク召喚
シークレットレイヤーですこの溝にいろいろも可愛いですようわぁ1枚5万5000円
です3枚で
ずう65,000円俺を人生たーーーーエンド戦闘機械なペンティシークレットレア
召喚32
ありませんあーそこそこだなぁで十分高いですね戦闘機ジーク
リンク昇桓は飼育って難です結構でも値段に幅がある生8000ぐらいにしておき
ましょう
最近デッキに入れた新たな相棒こいつで勝負を決めせ
値段的に釣行の光霊使いライナ召喚可愛いんすよイラストがこれも prismatic
シークレットレア
めっちゃ高い
がするああっ
43,000円くらいから4万3000くらいですがやっぱこの溝型のカードとやっぱ
高くなるんですよ
申請は幸を背例でしょうかんちょっとあのエッチなお姉さんですなー1万9800円だ
けど9800円で売ってるのでは1万円くらいにしましょう開く政府コード等カーを
リンク召喚これが氏切り抜けたと言っても過言でありません
大間々
まあまあ2万円ぐらいじゃないですが2万円です後はクリス撮ろうハリバイバー宿
プレミアフェニックスプレミアユニコーンさんないだいたい11000円くらいですは
高いは相棒
中継が終わったぜ
俺のエクストラ敵の値段は392,000円だ
おったまげー高いかが大体こんなもんだと思いますが倒れのサイドデッキ
近いのカードなどもめちゃくちゃ高いわけじゃないんですけども何枚かは高いと思うん
ですよこの禁ずられた一滴とかも結構高いと思うんですよちょっと際できるだけで値段
をまとめて紹介するぜ
う1枚にするんだどこー
アイゴでたぜええ他社と音やサイドデッキ15枚で4800円です
対してもダメなん
俺は疲れちまったぜ
こんばんに高いとはおっおおったより高かったっすねー
俺の予想だとだいたい100万円ぐらいだと思ってたんですけどちょっとオーバーして
ますがこれという理由でベッキーの合計金額だしていきましょう皆さんほど
コレクションカードと企画しないで下さいもう
web 戦うような対戦用の勝ちのデッキですデッキの値段が9087,360円
そしてエクス
のデッキ392,000円そしてサイドデッキ
41,800円俺がデッキの金額を
uo
俺とできる値段
14021,160円
ターンエンドぞ
[音楽]
bl 100枚
10優に超えてましたもうでも俺ほんと他の趣味とかが本当ゲームとカードゲームとか
スカなくて僕
あーおれこれはもちろんカードゲームとしても楽しむしこのリアリティというものも
あった楽しみたいと思っています
ただそれにしても高いはな本当に
[音楽]
142万か相棒
これが
デュエル人だ